l a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono fatti j ed oggi siamo sul
primo dei due video che usciranno perché
non usciranno due sulla mia avventura
all'e3 di los angeles del 2016 volevo
ringraziare di cuore nintendo per aver
permesso questa cosa perché abbiamo
fatto tutto questo grazie a nintendo è
tratto ci hanno fatto anche fare un tour
del loro stand che poi vi faccio vedere
nel video john betsch un los angeles
posso solo farvi capire perché un
aeroporto in germania e più figo di un
aeroporto in italia
grazie
avete la vostra risposta
[Musica]
allora ragazzi lo zio dio non zio lo zio
la calza no dai sono su un aereo ma non
è vero
dammi la calza casalin qui dai fratello
c'è chi dorme così e c'è chi dorme
così
l'uomo
si no
[Musica]
c'è la [ __ ] sulla settima siamo arrivati
all'hotel scegliere che bello sbatti
perché non ha tanti piani
siamo curiosi di vedere come sono le
camere perché ogni volta che veniamo in
america c'è sempre qualcosa di diverso
mi piace letto così alto ma dall acqua
panna a caso ci siamo fatti 10.000
chilometri di aereo per trovarci l'acqua
panna va bene vuoi fare il salto in
doppia io sono atletico perché sono
giovane io so fare sono stati euro 23
che bello un posto che non abbiamo mai
visto guardate sono stati quante volte
porca eva sono più qualche a casa mia
queste sono ciabatte comode ma gravanti
e comodo ma chi immagini inviare con il
con questa roba qua allora che ci ha
detto gesù che sono alla chitarra regata
[Musica]
in mezzo a due piccioni c'è sempre una
fava
ok
[Musica]
entrare nei self i della gente
questo il primo è né abbraccia il
signore veloce
ho visto una cosa che adoro lascia di
minecraft siccome per vincerla dobbiamo
fare non so quanti canestri penso 12
ci proviamo mi ha detto che ne devo fare
due per vincere la prima guerra come si
chiama
[Musica]
se lui è veramente il figlio di dio
questa palla entra anche tasto si tira
col quadrato mai un giorno
[Musica]
due su due adesso fra
però devo farne due
ho vinto questo e volevo portarmi al
caso una cazzo di ascia devi dargli un
nome a questo mostriciattolo chiamiamo
gesù ragazzi facciamo un contest se
questo video arriva a 100 mila like
regalano alieno della mi dice mi
spiegate come cazzo è possibile che su
una giostra del genere ci siano solo
persone adulte
ma hanno capito che sta roba per bambini
ok ragazzi siamo pronti con le nostre
macchine
andiamo per andare a venice beach con le
bike trial nei gas di ragazzi se questa
nuova pedalata su signora 9 bravo scarpe
belle scarpe belle scarpe fresche mai
farà il bagno intorno alla base per dire
non è tanto fredda
oggi il signor fa vige vi insegna come
mettere i costumi spiaggia partendo
dalle mutande senza prevedere un cazzo
di niente
prendete il costume di filati ad un
costo merda se le cose come stanno
evolvendo so che cosa mi prendesse le
mutande
la pace è vasco da gama
[Musica]
per morti ok ragazzi siamo usciti
c'è il concerto dei one direction ciao
draka
cos'è un ottimo protettore del niente
torniamo in un concreto preso 20 chili
bagnato ma ecco come copiare i compiti
fra ragazzi ci hanno portato un panino
di queste dimensioni
lo sapete
esatto io voglio sapere con quale
sfintere l'ok ago questo cosa l'italia
belgio a los angeles
il mio camion
compratevi big money ma cosa fa anche il
palo sasha che il palo esatto attenzione
ciliegina sulla torta surreal power
alberghi lorenzo per un bella tutti i
ragazzi urlato nelle orecchie tutte le
mattine
ma chi cazzo esto lorenzo che c'è
scritto ovunque a chi siamo da starbucks
e ci risiamo
pao cazzo vuol dire paolo giu ragazzi
miei iniziamo questa giornata con una
bella brioche mi sono dovuto mettere un
fazzoletto in faccia perché mi sono
fatto la barba e mi sono tagliato voi
direte ma che cazzo ti fai a fare la
barba che non c'è la barba non lo so
però lo faccio per sentirmi grande
andati ragazzi e benvenuti a questo non
so se sta proprio per
ma questa francia gente che mi riguarda
ci siamo ragazzi stiamo per entrare in
questo istante e voi cercate di non
fissarmi la lo squarcio farò in modo di
non farmelo notare siamo arrivati al 3
questa mattina e grosso i pony games
week
il gigantesco e fantastico siamo entrati
ragazzi nella lounge e dico io la prima
cosa l'ho fatta per sono entrato qui
dentro ovviamente per andare al buffet e
o [ __ ] tipo di 12 biscotti questo è
l'ultimo è un buonissimo
[Musica]
non ancora fatto a cazzotti ci credo
ragazzi come sapete la fiera di tre una
fiera di tecnologia quindi oggi vediamo
la tecnologia del 2016
venite con me
non sarà mai stato così facile pulirmi
il culo adesso stiamo andando da
nintendo che ha lo stand e forse più
grosso di tutto le tre che gigante
allora questa questo da una parte da
parte di destra che che continua per
chilometri fino a scampia e questa è la
parte dove ci faranno provare i giochi
tipo adesso vedrebbe e poi la piace
tutto il percorso di zelda dai ragazzi
di facilitare un attimo che cosa stanno
giocando tutti quanti zelda o guarda un
po da fare questa scelta
tale signora zelda
oddio stava andare contro cosa porca
[ __ ] sarri della pure qua ragazzi
incredibile sarà mica la novità
dell'anno zero
ciò che l'azienda non aveva detto se lo
fanno non lo fanno
la puoi avvicinare la prima cucina
remando nella vita reale che potrebbe
salutare
mai rischiato perché poi anche andar
nudo giusto
con i contenuti
oddio bello
ma dai ma seri
poteva fare questa cosa
ansa che gli ospiti già fatta bravo
telaio da tutto questo quasi che
macelleria area e va bene è troppo
divertente ragazzi perché sembra che
vuoi trovare il cibo guardate che roba
entra è veramente troppo figo sembra che
poi veramente raccogliere le cose tv
videogiochi perché ti devi ridurre così
donna perché
hakuna matata bello ma dopo di aprire
amintore cicala e dai dai dai
[Musica]
quanto fottutamente ra grossa questa
bistecca
e non c'e la prima macelleria
mamma dove sasha ecco ma come come fa
salire poi sempre sventura la chiamata
la cosa bella è che quel che noi siamo
solo scala mobile mondiale ma noi non è
su una scala mobile a lui sale così
quindi ragazzi questa era la prima parte
del dominus angeles riuscirà anche la
seconda più avanti pensate di poterci
arrivare a 426 mila 718 like per questo
video ok
nel caso schiacciate like condividete
questo video sul profilo facebook della
vostra nonna per farle vedere quant'è
bella los angeles come sayid ragazzi se
vi sia piaciuto il suo documento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook come
nei video tram descrizione sensori si
rischia 13 diavolo fosse video e ragazzi